and airman marquez start number 10 for
the rockies tonight two wins four losses
5.56 the earned run average
he went yes yeah
another victim of the slider and martay
he's kind of hanging around he's staring
down
marvin hudson and he went around yeah he
went around on the super super bowl i
think what's funny about how cantel
reacted he's like wait
and literally just got here less than a
minute ago and you're sending me back
that's a fastball drill down the line
blackman cuts it off in front of the
warning track haven smith heads for
third
make it a seven game hitting streak for
eduardo escobar
and you ask how coorsfield might
contribute to the offense getting
creative payment smith normally would
not go first to third on a hard hit ball
to the right fielder but in this
ballpark because charlie blackman is
playing so deep
babin is easily able to turn the corner
at second and ends up at third base here
comes a lefty that's done a lot of
damage against the rockies through the
years david peralta in fact his last 16
ball games against colorado he's hitting
364.
that is a big strikeout first and third
and two outs one one count on rojas
this should get him out of the inning
does not need assistance good job
warrior d back starter tonight is seth
frankov 32-year-old right-hander his
first career major league start came in
his d-back debut against the nationals
last saturday
he's jammed rolls it to the left side
long run for escobar his throw to first
not in time
escobar playing back and at the rim of
the infield came in on a ball that went
about
70 feet
and charlie hustled down the line and
beat escobar's throw keeps this inning
going for the cleanup hitters cj krohn
fired on the ricochet out to second but
charlie able to get in there on the wild
pitch
and a base hit to right and that wild
pitch is going to help the rockies take
a one-nothing lead
how about c.j krohn fellas take a
professional bat he's been one of the
better stories in baseball when you
think of a minor league sign and the
impact he's had on the big league team
gives ryan mcmahon a chance to hit 25th
pitch already this is a drive towards
left center field martay looking up it
is gone
touch him all time
ryan mcmahon
his tenth of the year
his fourth against arizona pitching
three
nothing rockies and now redick leads off
the second
sends this one out to right josh ranick
has got his first diamondbacks knock
it's a double to start the second
chance for nick ahmed now
and the foul tip is held he was a slider
i don't even know it was a great one but
it struck out nick the met
the third strikeout for her
you know it's almost like he was
guessing fastball 3-2 wasn't expecting
the slider
and there's the strikeout finally so
four strikeouts back to the top of the
order rymel tapia
rymel crushes it take a good look you
won't see it for long
second deck
fake it five nothing colorado
number five for rybal
and the rockies have the start they so
desperately needed offensively it's now
11 hits and 28 at bats against the
diamondbacks this season hanging
curveball it's up in the zone spilling
the thing i love most about his five
homers are all five run off speed
pitches
[Applause]
get a little stronger catch the ball out
front good job by herman another
strikeout that's five strikeouts
so far with one gun in the third and the
pitch swing and a miss says airmon
marquez went breaking ball and peralta
couldn't get it doesn't have a strikeout
tonight he's struggled through two
innings now i like to see him have a
quick one here i think so would his
defense o2 leaves the curve ball up and
gets a called strike on the inside
corner
and that's out number one he missed a
spot but got the call one out
they'll take that lead off strikeout
that's always a good feeling
[Applause]
seth frankov throwing strikes two up two
down in the third josh van meter will
pinch it one two pitch swag
and a miss
off speed and strikeout number seven
ryan mcmahon a 424
foot homer to left center field a two
run shot in the first inning
that drives us to center field indeed
martay going back and he'll watch this
sail out
second home run of the ball game for
mcmahon he continues to torment arizona
six nothing rockies
is 11. difference between one two and
two one is significant
line drive oh stabbed by story
you were talking about guys who had big
ups
story can climb the ladder if necessary
two outs
perfectly positioned perfectly timed
i mean he barely got
as high as he needed to there's there's
at least
10 more inches of vert there for trevor
story
one-two pitch to young and a cold strike
three and airmon marquez
leaves the two runners aboard
and fans young to end the top of the
seventh first and third you want to
continue to put
pressure on the defense plus we want
tacos
that'll work cj coming through again
tacos for everyone seven nothing
colorado has tapia scores
second hit second ribby the night for
crowd
a hanging slider and cj just stays on it
cj recognized
first and third
i get a pitch up sacrifice fly scores
the run
just take a nice easy swing and he did
it the bases are loaded for josh rojas
[Applause]
fastball punched the other way tapia
runs it down in the corner here comes
pavon
and the diamondbacks get on the board
7-1
[Applause]
well done by the rockies on both sides
the rockies pitched well behind that man
jeremiah marcus they swung the bat
exceptionally well they played very good
defense and they put a five-game losing
streak to bed